and do you think a lot of filmmakers get
overzealous and they put their first
feature in something thinking that is
going to work or I mean I mean yeah you
I mean I think you make it of course I
mean I'm in my first movie being like
it's gonna play at Sundance and then
it's gonna I get to make my next film I
mean you kind of have to have that like
vision for yourself but at the same time
it's not they shouldn't run they
shouldn't dictate everything and I think
of course if we can get your first film
to play their you absolutely should I
would play anything I could there um so
I certainly think you should always aim
the highest you can but also not I think
what happens then you put so much
expectation on it so much value on the
festival that then if you don't and I
see this it happened to me briefly and
I've seen it happen to a lot of people
that if you don't get in then you feel
like it's an indicative of your worth
you know it's like if you don't do well
on the SATs it makes you feel like
you're done when the STS don't really of
course you know that I mean they don't
have AIDS it's kind of the same feeling
it should it shouldn't dictate that at
all because they see so many films and
ultimately they have an mo they have a
certain amount of films certain program
a certain some movies with one storyline
and they want different storyline you
know they have their own goals that are
separate from your own and and having
said that too if you do get in and then
your movie doesn't blow up there you
know it's like if your movie doesn't
become another big overnight sales like
my movie wasn't a he it's gonna sell
we're gonna get distribution I'm really
happy about it people are gonna get a
chance to see it it's exactly what I
expected them path to go down but of
course you go to the festival hoping I'm
going to be you know beasts or I'm going
to be fruitvale or I'm going to be
whatever it might be you want to be like
that breakout but the but only one movie
or two movies every year got to be that
breakout so it's unfair for you put
yourself in that expectation to say well
if I don't break out from this and if
there are people knocking my door to
make the next film like it's it's that's
unreasonable to put onto any you can't
gauge what is gonna hit a certain
audience a certain time so anyways I
guess my whole goal is the whole thing
I'm going off on tangents but my whole
feeling about it is is that you can't
expect the industry now that I mean the
festival industry or the industry to
like hand you anything just because you
made your first film or even just
because you made your second film or
even just because you made your third
like I know if anything I've learned
along the way is it's like it's not
necessarily gonna get easier
to keep on proving yourself and you have
to keep on fighting for yourself sure
some people get their movie blows up and
then they get all the opportunities hand
to them but that's one out of every you
know 200-300 filmmakers you know and so
um doesn't mean that I'm going to stop
making films just because one movie to
do as well or as well as another movie
or something you know I think that you
can't you just can't expect you can hope
I guess plant you know it's like you can
plan for Sunday's but don't expect it
you can plan for success but don't
expect success cpap I think that that's
like the best advice not you put too
much pressure on yourself do you think
in some sense it almost gets harder
because people love discovering new
things and they want to embrace it and
they want to be the first jalan and then
once something's already established
then the peanut gallery comes out
whether it's from jealousy or just oh I
could have done a better job or whatever
only one seems like it's almost harder
in some sense some ways it gets harder
some ways it gets easier you know like I
said like casting got easier because I
can get access to these amazing actors
they love because they had a film to
show for myself so they could watch and
be like okay it takes away some risk for
them they can say I liked his first
movie so i'll but in other ways it gets
a lot harder because there isn't you're
not a blank slate anymore some people
can't people can't project how they
think you're going to be financed ears
can't from Jenna they can see your film
and then I can say well the first one
didn't really make that much money and
ya got awards but did how many people
saw you know whatever they can use that
is but i think the true people are going
to see potential you know the true
people who you want to collaborate with
will see what you were trying to do and
whether you achieved it or not and see
what how you might bring that into the
next film and grow from it um I hope
people see that but yeah I can get in
some ways it does get absolutely harder
it took longer for me to make my second
film in my first film and we made it
cheaper so you know it wasn't
necessarily money it's just the nature
of how challenging is the material
you